Is time travel possible?
Well, according to physicist, yes, time travel to the future is not only possible, it's
been scientifically proven.
But what about traveling to the past?
Well, that's a little trickier, but there does seem to be some evidence that travelers
from the future have visited us in the past and maybe among us right now.
Let's find out why. The laws of physics seem to be compatible with time machines.
This is very unsettling.
Welcome to the Y. Files were cool.
Nerds laugh and learn.
The human race has been fascinated with traveling through time ever since.
Well, ever since the human race understood the time was.
But as time travel than achieved by future humans.
And if so, did they leave us clues that they were here?
We've scoured the Internet for the best time travel stories we can find.
You may know some of them. Some may be new to you.
Some are hoaxes. A few have been debunked.
But there are a couple of stories that defy explanation.
Let's get into it. In 1950, a New York City police officer working missing persons cases
examined
the body of a 30 year old man who was brought to the morgue.
The man had appeared in the middle of Times Square at 11, 15 p.m.
that evening, and witness described him as gawking and looking around at the cars and at
the signs like he'd never seen them before.
He then tried to cross the street against the traffic lights, was hit by a speeding taxi
and died.
Pockets of his clothing had coins and currency that had not been in circulation for
decades.
Yet many of them were in mint condition.
He also had items from businesses that no longer existed in New York City, like a bill
from a livery stable, a brass slug from a saloon and a letter postmarked
1876. He also had identification bearing the name Rudolph Fense with an address on Fifth
Avenue.
Now the name Rudolph Fense didn't appear in the New York City phone book, and the Fifth
Avenue address listed on the dead man's car had been a business for many years, not a
residence. And no one there had ever heard of Rudolph fense.
The deceased fingerprints matched nothing on file, and no current police reports fit the
man's description.
Also, his clothes appeared to be about seventy five years out of date.
Tags on his clothing had a name and address of a tailor that no one had ever heard of,
and his hat, which looked new, came from a shop that had been closed for over 50 years.
The investigating officer finally turned up a listing in an old phone book for Rudolph
Fense Jr., a man in his 60s who had passed away five years earlier.
Now his widow is still living and said her husband's father, Rudolph Fense Senior, had
disappeared sometime in the eighteen seventies.
He had gone out for a walk one night about 10:00 p.m., but was never seen again.
This is crazy.
I know. So a search of an old missing person's report turned up a Rudolph fence dated
1876, and the man's clothing and address matched those of the
man killed in Times Square in 1950.
So that missing persons case was finally closed after seventy five years.
But a different case remains open.
What really happened to Rudolph?
Depending on it or a trajectory you take around a black hole, you can come out and end up
in the past of when you started.
In 2003, the FBI arrested forty four year old Andrew Carlson for suspicion of insider
trading and just two weeks, Carlson had made one hundred and twenty six
consecutive high risk profitable trades, turning his eight hundred dollars of seed
capital into a portfolio worth three hundred and fifty million dollars.
Naturally, the SEC wanted this looked into.
Naturally, people with money don't want anyone else making money.
I can't deny that. Now, normally when someone is arrested for insider trading, they deny
it.
But during a four hour interrogation, investigators got an explanation they didn't
expect.
Carlson stated he traveled back in time from two hundred and fifty years in the future,
bringing knowledge of high risk, high profit stock trades.
In his videotaped confession, Carlson said it was just too tempting to resist.
He'd plan to make it look natural by losing a little here and there, but got caught up in
the moment.
So the SEC said he was either a lunatic or a pathological liar because the only way he
could pull this off was with illegal information.
And they said he's going to sit in jail until he agrees to give up his sources.
But Carlson did not give up his sources.
He stuck to his story even in the future.
Snitches get stitches.
Yeah. So knowing he was going to prison, Carlson said in exchange for a lighter sentence,
he'd be willing to reveal the cure for AIDS and the location of Osama bin
Laden. He also said he didn't care about the money.
Give it back. He just wanted to return to his time craft and go back to his own time.
But he refused to reveal the location of the craft for fear that it would fall into the
wrong hands.
So bail was set at one million dollars and he was put into a holding to await trial.
And you would think that's the end of the story.
Carlson had no family, no friends, and no longer had any money.
But after a few weeks in custody, a mysterious unidentified man posted Karlsson's bail of
a million dollars whacked.
Who was the mystery man?
Well, we don't know. The mystery man and Carlson were never seen or heard from again.
And even stranger.
There is no record of anyone named Andrew Carlson before the day he was arrested.
A question for you.
Yeah. Did he mention anything about games that time travel is possible if you're focusing
upon time travel to the
future? Ok, this one gives me chills, Tyson's boxing match with Peter McNeilly in
nineteen
ninety three was notable for being Iron Mike's first since his release from prison.
It lasted only eighty nine seconds and was stopped after McNeilly was knocked down twice.
But the most remarkable moment occurred outside of the ring, where footage shows a
spectator holding up a smartphone years before they were invented.
The white colored camera has the distinctive slimline design of a smartphone with the
lens in the top left corner.
Another innovation associated with modern day recording equipment.
All right, enough talk. You've got to take a look at this.
What is that?
I honestly don't know, camcorders were everywhere in the 90s, but they were bigger than
this and this guy obviously is holding it with one hand.
A lot of people think it looks like an iPhone or a Samsung Galaxy, but those wouldn't be
invented for years, so.
Time travel.
This is a famous photo known as the Time Traveling Hipster, the image comes from the
Braylon Pioneer Museum in British Columbia, and the photograph was taken in 1940 at the
reopening of the South Fork Bridge in Canada.
When the museum digitized the photo and put it online in 2010, people noticed something
strange.
At first glance, everything looks right.
The men are in jackets, ties and hats, the women and bonnets and overcoats.
But look at this. Well, this guy appears to have a modern haircut, sunglasses, and he's
wearing a graphic tee shirt under his cardigan.
And what's that he's holding?
Doesn't that seem too small to be a camera in 1940 Photoshop?
No. The museum has confirmed that the photo is authentic and unaltered.
So who is he?
Where is he from? Don't you mean when is it from?
Paths through space time that seem to be permitted by the laws of physics, although it
would require a very high advanced technology, much more advanced than us to do it.
Out of place, technology seems to pop up all over the place if you look for it.
In 2010, a video called Chaplin's Time Traveler appeared on YouTube, and the clip
analyzes bonus material from a DVD of Charlie Chaplin's nineteen twenty eight film Circus.
Now, the footage is from the film's Los Angeles premiere at Grauman's Chinese Theater.
And at one point, a woman is seen walking by, holding up an object to her ear and a
closer examination.
She seems to be talking into a thin black device.
What is this? There are no cell towers or satellites yet, so it's not a modern cell phone.
What is it? She's definitely talking, but there's nobody else near her.
Who is she talking to?
She's talking to other time agents.
She's saying this really sucks.
Let's get in and out burger Inkscape.
Maybe in a few years later.
This happened again.
This is footage from nineteen thirty eight of people coming out of a Dupont factory.
And the woman in the center seems to be talking on a cell phone or some communication
device and then puts it away.
Now, this video was so convincing that it's been covered by the Huffington Post, Daily
Mail and Yahoo!
News now plays what Yahoo!
News should change its name to Yahoo!
Random words that she never believed.
Let's say you don't trust the media.
I love fish, not a sheep.
Fine. I got it.
No trust the media. Get a boy.
Anyway, Haggerty's Digital Archive has full scans of every issue of the magazine from
nineteen thirteen to nineteen ninety three, and there's no mention of a wireless
communication device around the time of the film.
So you tell me who she talking to?
Mission Control and the mothership.
Out of place, technology can be found not just in film or old photographs, but in art
created hundreds or thousands of years ago.
Here are a few famous ones.
In 2008, a team of archaeologists had made a puzzling discovery.
The team included some journalist.
They were filming a documentary to dig site at a sealed tomb dating to the Ming Dynasty
at Shanxi, northern China.
As one of the coffins were being cleared of soil before being opened, a strange metallic
object was found.
It was a small golden ring with a watch face on its front, approximately two millimeters
thick, tiny hands on the watch show.
The time had frozen at ten oh six.
The most astonishing of all.
The back of the watch had the word Swiss engraved in English that the tomb had been
sealed for four hundred years and the watch itself was already one hundred years old when
it was placed inside.
That dates to the 15th or 16th century.
Switzerland wasn't even known by that name in English until eighteen forty eight.
It is like a time traveler lost and found it kind of is.
The Spanish city of Salamanca features a cathedral built in 11 to the carvings are pretty
typical for the 12th century.
Winding vines and leaves, gargoyles, demons.
No, they go up. But what the heck is this?
That appears to be a modern astronaut wearing a spacesuit and not just a random
spacesuit.
This particular suit has features specific to the Apollo 11 emu worn by Buzz Aldrin.
You can see the helmet, the backpack which held the primary life support system and
oxygen umbilical cords are so underrated.
They are. But what really got me were the boots.
They feature deep treads that would be used to explore dusty extraterrestrial surfaces
like the moon and Mars.
And he appears to be floating like he's on a spacewalk.
So how could the artist have predicted all these details almost 900 years before they
were invented?
One point twenty one was.
Ok, these stories are certainly fun, but are they real?
Can they be explained? Maybe you'll be the judge.
Let's go through the case of Rudolfensis, an urban legend that's been around since the
1970s, maybe even earlier.
I first heard it from my dad when I was a kid, but it's not true.
It's actually an excerpt from a short story called I'm Scared, which was written by Jack
Finney, you might know, is the author of The Body Snatchers.
The story was published in Collier's magazine in 1951, about the time when Rudolfensis
supposedly appeared.
Nice to believe it. I know you did.
The Andrew Carlson story is one of my favorites.
I love this one. It has all the makings of a great conspiracy, millions of dollars, a
mysterious benefactor, a missing person.
But this one originated as a fictional piece in Weekly World News, a satirical newspaper.
Later, the story was picked up by Yahoo!
News. So naturally, people believe the story.
It was then reported by other newspapers and magazines as fact.
And this drove word of mouth, creating one of the great modern urban legends.
So the lesson here, we don't believe anything the media says you're learning.
Ok, so the Mike Tyson fight, although the device in the video does resemble a type of
camera phone not sold until years later.
It also could be one of a number of handheld cameras that were, in fact, widely
available.
The resolution and size of the original video make it difficult to determine the specific
features of the device.
But some believe it's similar to either the Casio covid 10 a the Casio Cuvee one hundred
or the Logitech Fotomat.
So debunked probably maybe.
I'm not sure if you think you know what kind of camera that is, please let us know in the
comments.
The idea that the hipster in the photograph is a time traveler hinges on three items that
appear to be too modern for 1940 a logo, t shirt, a small portable camera and the
wraparound sunglasses.
But all of those items were readily available in the 1940s.
The Internet says he's wearing a Montreal Maroons embroidered jersey.
And the Marines were a hockey team that played in the NHL from nineteen twenty four to
nineteen thirty eight.
Ok, while glasses with protective side shields were not widespread, you could get them in
1940 and the camera in his hand.
There definitely were cameras that small back then.
They were unusual and they're pretty expensive.
But they did exist.
So debunked.
No. The woman on the cell phone, quote unquote, in the Charlie Chaplin clip, is thought to
be using an early hearing aid, though I'm not sure why she's talking to herself and
looking around like people do when they're on the phone.
But she could be talking to herself.
I mean, I do that when I'm alone.
Do we really want to discuss what you do when you're alone?
No, I don't.
But the Dupont video from nineteen thirty eight is a little trickier.
After the story went viral, the woman's family claimed that her name was Gertrude Jones
and she was working for Dupont and using an experimental wireless telephone developed by
the company. OK, that's fine, but look at the size of it.
The earliest cell phones were huge and this is before World War Two.
So you're telling me we had the technology to make batteries that small?
OK, fine. Let's say the battery technology did exist.
It wouldn't be big enough to power a wireless radio.
The walkie talkie was only patented in 1936, and in the war, radio operators were
followed around by another guy with a backpack that carry the transceiver
and battery, which weighed over 30 pounds, 18 kilograms.
So heavy. So I don't know if this one is debunked.
The ancient watch found in the Chinese tomb.
That's a straight up hoax.
Photoshopped debunked the astronaut on the Cathedral of Salamanca.
Well, the sculpture is definitely real.
But when the cathedral was renovated and restored in 1992, the artist added their own
modern touches, including the astronaut debunked crap.
Those good one. I know they were.
But three or four hundred years from now, when someone looks at that church, they are
going to be confused.
They say time is the fire in which we burn.
So why do we want so badly for these stories to be true, why are we so obsessed with time
travel?
Well, probably because we're obsessed with time.
Time rules our lives.
Time creates possibilities.
The time also ends possibilities.
It's finite. The expression time is money isn't exactly true.
Time is much more valuable than money.
Wealth can be made and lost and made again.
But time once we lose it, we can never get it back.
Time is the most valuable thing you have.
Spend it wisely. Thanks for hanging out with us today.
My name is A.J. That Tigerfish, this has been the Y files.
If you had fun or learned anything today.
Help us out by liking, commenting or sharing this video.
Only with your help can we defeat the algorithm.
Let's crush the algorithm until this time.
Be safe. Be kind and know that you are appreciated.